welcome back I tried to start doing
problem number two in the last video but
I realized I was running out of time so
let me start over
problem number 10 the Smith metals
company old machine makes 300 bolts per
hour 300 bolts per hour this new machine
makes 450 bolts per hour so 450 volts
per hour
if both machines begin running at the
same time how many minutes will it take
the two machines to make a total of 900
volts so the important thing to realize
is that they said minutes
they said minutes so we could convert
both of these rates to minutes now or we
could say how many hours is it going to
take and then convert that to two
minutes after we have our answer
actually let's do it the second way
let's say how many hours and then
convert that to minutes so let's say we
want to produce this human-produced 900
bolts 900 bolts and how much we're gonna
produce in each hour well they're both
running at the same time right so we're
gonna produce in every hour we're gonna
produce 300 plus 7 plus 450 bolts we're
gonna produce 750 bolts per hour right
750 bolts per hour bolts per hour times
let's say X hours X hours I the unit's
might confuse you so just leave out the
unit's this is how many hours it takes
to produce 900 bolts so you divide both
sides by 750 you get X is equal to 90
900 over 750 let's see what I can do
here to see if I divide the top and the
bottom by 30 the top will become C it'll
become 30 over and then the bottom I
could if I 75 divided 3 is 20 75 divided
by 3 is 25 so right so 30 over 25 and
then I could let's see 5 is a common
factor I could do it all in one fell
swoop so that's 6 over 5 so it's gonna
take 6 over 5 hours
that's how long it's gonna take us how
many minutes is that
well every hour is one minute I mean
every hour is 60 minutes it's getting
late so six over five hours
you just have to multiply it by 60 to
get how many minutes is equal to what
see you cancel this five and make this a
12 six times 12 is 72 minutes and that
is choice B next problem I've been using
this yellow awhile let me switch problem
11 the table above gives the values of
the linear function G for selected
values of T which of the following
defines G okay so they so they say T
they say G of T and they say they go
from negative 1 0 1 2 let's see it's 4 2
4 2 0 minus 2 so the one thing I always
look at is what G of 0 is because that
tends to be interesting especially when
I look at all of the choices all of the
choices are of this form they're all of
the form and times T plus B right where
m is a sloping if you're familiar with
linear equations you remember this form
and so when T equals 0 G of T tells you
what the y-intercept is going to be
right so let's see G of 0 G of 0 is
equal to 2 so that tells us that this
equation G of T is going to be equal to
the slope times T plus 2 right because
when T was 0 all we had left with was 2
and so immediately we can cancel out all
but the last two choices right so the
last 2 choices choice D is G of T is
equal to minus T plus 2 and then the
last choice is G of T is equal to minus
2 T plus 2 let's see which one of these
works we can try out some numbers so
what happens when T is negative 1 when T
is negative 1
this expression becomes negative 1 times
negative negative negative 1 is
positive 1 so this becomes 3 that's not
right this one becomes negative 2 times
negative 1 is positive 2 plus 2 so this
becomes 4 so we can immediately cancel
this one out because it didn't here for
this G of T G of negative 1 equal 3 and
they tell us right here is plus equal 4
this one worked and this is kind of the
only one that still works it has a 2 for
the y-intercept and when you evaluated
for just even the first point you got
the right answer so that's the answer
answers e next problem
ok survey results I guess I should draw
this I haven't read the question but
it's probably important let's see
there's about five squares that way so
five squares that way somebody said to
draw four lines let's go one two three
four and then eight lines have to draw
one it's always hardest part just
drawing these diagrams two three four
and you're learning how to count five
six seven almost there and eight all
righty
and then they say these are the grades
the y-axis is grade grade 9 10 11 12 the
x-axis is distance to school and miles
one two three four five six seven eight
and these are the points 1 comma 10 is
right here 2 comma 9 2 comma 9 to come
11 3 comma 10 3 comma 10 3 comma 12
for kamma ic4 is at 10 and 11 5 they
have one point at 11 6 is 3 points right
here 10 11 12 see there's a point here
here here and then a point here and here
now we can start the problem the results
of a survey of 16 students at Thompson
high school are given in the grid above
it shows the distance to the nearest
mile that students at various grade
levels travel to school so this is miles
and this is grade according to the grid
which of the following is true so I'll
just read them out a there's only one
student who travels two miles to school
see two miles false there is two
students there's this guy and this guy
so it's not a choice be half of the
students travel less than 4 miles to
school less than 4 miles so that's less
than 4 miles is everyone to the left of
this line right and this is you one two
three four five five out of 16 is not
half so we know it's not choice B see
more 12th graders and 11th graders
travel six miles or more to school so
more they're saying more 12th graders
and 11th graders so six miles or more so
let's see six miles or more was it's
anything to the right of this line right
that's six miles or more there are three
12th graders and how many 11th graders
are there and there oh there are two
11th graders I think that is correct
more 12th graders and 11th graders
travel six or more miles to school right
six or more miles three 12th graders -
eleventh graders that's our answer our
answer is C next path Lex problem known
amount of time for this one I'll try
problem 13 how many positive three-digit
integers positive three dinners
have the hundreds digit equal to three
and the unit's digit is equal to four so
it's gonna be like three blank four so
how many numbers are here well how many
digits can we stick in for that well we
could put a 0 a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 or 9
there we could put any of those in that
middle spot and that there are 10 digits
we can put there so there are 10
possibilities there 10 positive 2
designers that have the hundreds digit
equal to 3 and the unit's digit equal to
4 that's choice a that's one of those
problems that it's you question yourself
because it seems maybe even too easy
I'll see you in the next video